there aren't many things that can get us
out of bed at 5 00 a.m but
tom cruise and emily blunt kicking off a
24-hour premiere marathon
at london's bfi imax is one of them
30 seconds to drop
yes like their characters in new movie
edge of tomorrow they're racing against
time
and have to get to three global
premieres in just 24 hours
though that's nothing compared to the
action in the film
very unique cinema experience with
wonderful action wonderful characters
and story
and it was great to play the brave one
the courageous one while he's the coward
it was a kind of royal reversal for tom
come find me when you wake up
edge of tamar is like a big big story
it's a
million soldiers storming into mainland
europe
these are these are big big scenes and
so you need a big canvas so
imax is the perfect format for a movie
of the skin
they have the power to reset the day and
now so do you how do i control it
you have to die i love imax it's big
scale
big scope big screen the sound that's
that's why
you know this is i love doing my
premieres here we make the films from x
well what the imax experience brings to
this film
is the epic cinematic scale that we
always
intended it to have and i think just to
maximize the viewing pleasure of this
movie
and the entire experience of this movie
i think it's a shame not to see it in
imax
i love shooting out of leaves but i love
landing in trafalgar square it's
a beautiful city i think we showcase it
wonderfully because we did six weeks
filming outside it pretty much was like
this every day
i love everything about london even the
weather i like here i've come back to
london in a second
and now they're off to paris shortly
followed by new york and we're off to
get some coffee
with extra caffeine
you